now this is such a counter-intuitive tip
but it could make you Millions as an
online writer give away 99 of what you
know for free right what the mistake
everyone makes is they go I'm gonna
productize myself and before I tell you
anything you have to pay for it well
it's the same mistake as providing a
service right you don't walk up to
someone and go hey before you know what
I can do here's how much it costs
they're like get out of here but if you
start by going here's everything here's
here's here's how to think about it
here's how to solve the problems here's
everything you need to know the person
then goes well if all the free stuff was
so great then what's in the paid stuff
most courses most books most paid
membership communities all that you
aren't really buying information what
you're buying is implementation you're
buying accountability you're buying
access to the person that you want to
learn from